okay we're on the internet now let's ask
the questions that have come in from the
viewers black night ask Jeffrey
gentlemen Oh their usual or just sound
this is visual for all the resources in
humanitarian aid they are given why
can't African nations develop ooh well I
think some of them have right not
probably because of the aid but there's
there's a lot of African success stories
right definitely and there's also a long
history of a lot of these countries have
tried to do what European nations in the
United States did and hundreds of years
are trying to do it and you know 10 20
30 40 years so I think it's very high
expectations to expect the same level of
development or even democracy in these
countries that we all associate with
Europe and the United States people used
to call I forget the Dark Continent I
disappointed that we don't recognize as
development but in in Africa its
development right you know running
running water yeah absolutely well I
mean look there are parts of this
country that are third-world there are
parts of Africa I'm sure which are much
more preferable to stay and then parts
of you know Appalachia something a
friend of mine travels to some third
world countries and she was amazed when
she came back here how much to see how
much we waste drinking water
I'll see that too one nice thing about
Africa's there's not a lot of waste
people recycle everything they they care
for their resources you see people
wearing second-hand clothes I mean if
that's one thing I like about it it's
kind of a statement that we could live
with a lot less but it is the Dark
Continent
but there's a certain business because
they're people of color there yeah
but like when when Brad Pitt and
Angelina Jolie the remember that story
that they first got together and I think
it was Namibia and their lovemaking was
so powerful it scared the natives scared
the animals or something it did it was
so scary I swear I read that and I
believe everything I read like the guy
in spinal tap okay what is it with this
is for you Michelle bruh what what is it
with women's latest fascination with the
book oh the that we just did Fifty
Shades of Grey what it but that is a
phenomenon where you know I flew out
here yesterday and I read the first
volume on the airplane and I bought the
second volume on my iPad I'm in Paris to
say I don't know what it is it's it's a
fascinating book it's interesting it's
good it's my wife is read all three
that's one hundred and fifty Shades of
Grey she has not asked for a divorce yet
I have and MIT Romney has a book 50
shades of white it's you know some
people call it like the feminist dream
it's you know it's romantic there's a
lot of I guess you call it snn there's a
lot of very heavy-duty wild sex in the
book but but also at the same time the
the female who's the lead character she
says no she says yes she's in charge
she's not in charge it's I don't know
how you wrap your hands around all I can
say is it's it's interesting and it's
it's must read they're not in charge
they want to be they don't want to be
yeah I mean they're complicated
all depends on timing yeah yeah we say
if you're married 20 years and you come
home and you throw your wife down on the
kitchen tables you'd love it but don't
do it on the first day yeah I had the
same reaction when I read men are from
Mars Women are from Venus I just went
crazy you know you went to your man cave
yeah let's go from that to it's the
current economic crisis in Europe a
repudiation against having a single
currency is the current economic crisis
in Europe a repudiation against having a
single currency totally totally I think
there's a lot of goodness no I mean that
they're saying that Greece might leave
the eurozone do you think that's
possible that's a near certainty I mean
that's that's almost a done deal how
many dominoes fall afterwards that's but
is that by the way this is hell on earth
I mean this is you know 50% unemployment
among young people in Greece and Spain
so you know from 50 shades of gray to
serious stuff this is this is an ongoing
catastrophe and it's a political
catastrophe to take a look at at at some
of the movements that are on the rise in
Europe right now Golden Dawn in Greece
yogic and Hungary and tell me take a
look at those photos and ask if you
don't think that you just stepped
through a time portal back to the year
1932 this is scary scary it is and then
you look at the US I mean we have our
problems in the minority groups and the
youth and the uneducated huge ones like
this I mean you have 50% or higher in
black teenage unemployment and it's been
going on for five years I mean these
kids after not working for five years
they won't have the requisite skills to
be able to and then you'll find all of
these problems lasting for a long long
time and you must see that in Africa all
that I mean I was down there with the e
booze in the Yoruba
oh you're curious it's excellent
denunciation voluma - yeah but that but
I love it they were all my students and
it's amazing that what goes on in wait
you you taught it now further how do I
give lectures down there for that I
don't think they say down there like
it's well yeah it's I think why would
people why would people want to work in
Greece because there's just so many fun
things to do let me say where the Greeks
actually worked longer hours than the
Germans this is a great myth it's a
tremendous myth that there's all because
they're lazy then when they screwed up
policy they made a lot of mistakes they
were enabled in making a lot of mistakes
by German banks that lent the money no
questions asked so this is you know
don't don't buy into the German notion
that it's all their fault it's not this
was a collective mistake and if the
we're gonna see whether the Europeans
can get their act together and if not
Wow
but the question I would ask you Paul I
mean this one is you know how is that I
mean here's the stimulus spending and
all that deficit spending the one on
increase how is that not the same every
same you know spending Greece there was
never they they ran deficits in good
years because they were out of control
that was I had nothing to do with
stimulus that is my frame actually done
now is they've had enormous cuts in
spending in a depression and the result
is to make the depression really deeper
and we say our depression is not as bad
as the Great Depression but there's is
and that's the lesson if you want to
know who could make us like Greece it is
those Republicans in Congress who want
us to do even more austerity in the face
of a depression I don't right
[Applause]
Real Time with Bill Maher
ask bill and its guest your questions
right after the show
at hbo.com